eddie you're kind of
would that would be right saying your
sexual awakening was
was sort of was a two-dimensional
sexual awake thing oh god
i hate new year
um no it's true that i i was once
interviewed as i was like you know who
were your first crushes and and um
and i did i i loved the lion king when i
was younger and i had a weird obsession
with nala
but
[Applause]
look at her face she's so sweet
and she can sing really well
that's wrong
and is it true you like made marion as
well
yes that is true she's a fox though well
i have that too yeah do you
oh that's oh
no no no but in eddie's difference
in his defense they drop him really
sadly
what did you like robin hood
was quite sexy we've got robin hood
there he is
and that tunic is worn very low i
noticed yeah he's packing
we forced you to say you had a slight
inc
not a yen for wilma will mcflinstone
yeah yeah
what's not to like
that was a hot cartoon lady yeah
and then we asked bradley but you you
were top of your head you were just like
oh yeah yeah sexy cartoons got them so
who who did you like well there's two of
them
how old you are shero
who'd oh look at shira and then chitara
shitara classic
oh my god cause she wrote quickly now a
lot of people don't know this but eddie
is in fact a highly trained master
magician are you a member of the magic
circle um
no
[Applause]
wow that moment was one of like deep
despair and lobster that was a dream
when i was a child that never happened
yeah please tell me you're about to
about your about no because i know that
i know that you can do amazing magic
because we have here just a totally
ordinary coloring book oh this is
totally ordinary
oh
but eddie can do magic with it
isn't that right eddie i mean
are you sitting comfortably children
no oh
it's totally ordinary but you mustn't
touch it
okay i'm sorry eddie's got it so excited
so i loved paul daniels you probably
won't know who will tell you the late
paul daniels was an amazing magician
that used to be on telly every saturday
night i was obsessed with him and i this
is my moment to be on television doing
magic ben are you ready i'm ready i'm
ready this is a coloring book there is
nothing weird odd or bizarre about it
other than it says the word magic on the
front of it
there is actually nothing in the
coloring book i'm showing you do you see
there is
but
ryan yes
will you blow on the coloring book
i thank you pardon
no harder than that
[Laughter]
come on
[Applause]
let's let's see what that's done shall
we
oh wow
that is some
crazy okay
uh okay so the next stage is so we've
got now we have pictures ben we have
pictures we have pictures i can see the
pictures
will you
blow on it
give me your full smog card
[Laughter]
[Applause]
drum roll oh
thank you for appeasing my greatest
him burn him
the thing is because it's so unusual to
have two such young oscar winners you
know this is normally something
happening that's why we're friends yeah
you're part of an elite club but the
other thing you share is quite
short-lived careers in modeling oh i
thought you just said yeah
wow i was like oh
happy new year
so so because you now what was your big
break was it vogue squire
i think all of the above talk about
modeling talk about it or was it in fact
actually my model i think he's about to
talk about the model oh my god
yes because he did you look at these
like it's hard to make a jumper sexy
true though
jumper i think
he's managing
[Applause]
i mean seriously here's the thing
your sweater has eyeballs
that was a high point but i think you
can actually still buy that and it's the
point of that is you can learn to knit
it yourself
so you you guys can take one of those
home and knit it yourself actually i can
buy the sweater and then i have to do it
myself yeah as well actually there's a
classic thing in here so you know when
you want something for christmas and you
say to like your mom or your granny i'd
really like a really trendy sweat top
i'd like a really nice trendy zippy up
set top
and then they knit it for you
no
that's the christmas nightmare isn't it
but you still do some modeling don't you
sporadically and very unsuccessfully oh
stop it you do big rounds
well i did do i did some um i did a
campaign for burberry which was very
amazing and i did it a few years ago and
mario testino shot it
and i remember doing it was when i was
just starting out and then in this
photograph there was a sort of there was
a a model and
me an actor wannabe actor and a um
musician
and married christina who i've never
worked with who is one of the most
extraordinary brilliant people but he's
just almost in that moment he was almost
like a sort of parody of himself so we
had to run and jump for the photograph
and he goes he's literally got the
camera there and he goes okay so darling
you supermodel you rockstar eddie you
movie star i'm mario testino i wanted to
go
[Laughter]
[Applause]
these two sort of pros and me with this
but he gets the photos because they're
so natural ones of sort of shock and
minor despair and uh wonder i think at
the same time because you you you don't
have my picture no i don't because i'll
tell you why yes tell us why because
it's really amazing to get an
abercrombie model yeah i have a probably
a
don't don't make your hoots please still
be into the story
so
my pictures never came out i did like
the whole campaign and the pictures
never came out and i didn't know why my
agent wrote and asked why and they
literally only responded with the photos
because
they like their whole like idea was like
we want real people so they you know
they like got i don't know we were like
on a beach and then they threw us a
football and they're like play football
and all the other models were like
playing football like in a pretty way
you know like and not me
i was all of the photos i've got a red
face covered in sweat my nostrils are
flared
and like at one point a girl yelled just
get her away from me
[Applause]
how come it sounds like jk rowling has
just spilled her guts to you you know
you know stuff that he doesn't well no i
i'm not sure we haven't we haven't
cross-referenced this yet actually but i
when i was asked to to play the part the
first thing i felt was my responsibility
was to meet jk rowling and to question
her about the the backstory and the um
the life of this incredible character
because he is hugely beloved and i felt
like it was a big responsibility so she
talked through
uh his childhood a lot of which we all
know from the harry potter books
up to this point and she went a little
beyond but not hugely i mean and most of
what she told me was about albus not
about everyone else so i you know i know
a little bit i'm really sticking to this
don't talk about it closely don't
pretend you stick to the secrecy clause
oh that's fun of doing these films
if you're an actor and you get cast as
young dumbledore the one thing you do
know is you live yeah yes
i'm in all these thoughts
nothing's happening you could die you
could die that was all good
all i have to worry about is growing up
keeping that beard growing that's it
yeah yeah but a big reaction from sort
of a confused reaction from fans here
are some of the tweets uh when it got
announced i mean dumbledore just got 200
percent harder oh my god here's another
one uh jude law is playing a young hot
and gay dumbledore in the next venezuela
i'm sweating already
this this this i think sums it up quite
nicely dumbledore more like dumbledown
[Applause]
[Music]